à 15 ans qu'elle est attendue
la suite des aventures de la famille de
super héros sort au mois de juillet un
des rendez vous internationaux de 2018
une année ou deux grands noms vont se
côtoyer steven spielberg
woody allen ou encore clint eastwood ou
d'y aller a dit clint eastwood alors il
ya deux catégories de films art et essai
ce sont des films art et serge précise
un woody allen
clint eastwood est à l'arrêt ses
porteurs comme on dit dans le jargon du
métier c'est assez les films de grands
cinéastes connus qui ont pignon sur rue
alors des fois on a des surprises il ya
des films qui qui font des gros succès
comme ça et qu'ils sortent qui sont des
surprises tout simplement parce que le
réalisateur n'est pas connue et cetera
elle le cinéma français ne sera pas en
reste la nouvelle comédie de dany boon
lâcheté de famille cent en février
le 31 janvier le public pourra aussi
découvrir le troisième volet des
aventures des tuche
les français aiment beaucoup la comédie
alors après j'ai pas vu les films dont
il faut qu'il soit réussi
les tuche en général ça marche très bien
c'est olivier baroux qui réalise comme
les deux premiers épisodes
bon ben vous connaissez tous les tuche
enfin j'imagine
cette famine de comment dirais-je de 2,2
pauvres c'est à dire entre guillemets
s'en occupent des chances terre qui se
retrouvent dans des situations
complètement hallucinante et parce
qu'une année cinéma sans un nouveau star
wars n'en est pas une
le 23 mai rome - vous embarque dans le
passé de han solo